[Musik]
jetzt reagiert Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
mit dem doppelwumms wie er selbst heute
sagte der Staat investiert 200
Milliarden in seiner energiepreisbremse
beruhigt das die Bürger rettet das die
Wirtschaft außerdem neu auf dem Markt
die angepassten Corona Impfstoffe 13
Millionen impfzertifikate sind
abgelaufen doch wie sicher ist die
Impfung eigentlich es gibt viel zu
besprechen mit diesen Gästen heute abend
Wirtschaftsjournalist und Chefredakteur
des wirtschaftskuriers Oliver Stock sein
Thema heute abend Friedensverhandlungen
statt Eskalation auch heute Abend bei
uns der Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer
der FDP Bundestagsfraktion und Mitglied
im Bundesvorstand der FDP Thorsten
Herbst er sich sicher Deutschland wird
zum energiepolitischen Geisterfahrer
ökoimmunologe und Sachbuchautor Clemens
Arbeit er warnt vor der corona-impfung
warum er das tut und auf welcher Basis
darüber sprechen wir gleich ich bin sehr
gespannt last but not least dr Christoph
Specht erst medizinjournalist und Arzt
für Präventionsmedizin seine These
weniger Ärzte mehr Gesundheit macht
erstmal keinen ich bin gespannt mich
beschäftigt aktuell aber nicht die
Medizin sondern ein Tweet der Grünen
Bundestagsabgeordneten Kathrin
Henneberger besser formuliert er macht
mich wirklich fassungslos Henneberger
twitterte nämlich ich muss wirklich also
die groß ist besser und vor der kam mit
also ein Schrumpfen der Wirtschaft
lassen Sie es mich einmal ganz deutlich
sagen die groß ist nicht besser sondern
asozial und es wirtschaftsfeindliche
Weltbild der Grünen was hier offenbart
wird muss endlich enden ich weiß nicht
wie es Ihnen zu Hause geht aber ich habe
für diese Kapitalismuskritik mit
Airports kein Verständnis mehr den
meistens kommt diese Kritik ja exakt von
den Menschen die mehr auf Abruf haben
Menschen die Frau hennenberger die als
Bundestagsabgeordnete über 10.000 Euro
pro Monat verdient wer sich also
ausstellt ausgestattet mit einem hohen
Gehalt und einem sicheren Job hinstellt
und fordert die Welt sollte sich vom
wachstumsgetriebenen Geschäftsmodell
verabschieden der verhält sich nur
asozial ich muss das so hat sagen denn
für Menschen Entwick Schwellenländern
ist es keine Alternative auf weltweites
Wachstum zu verzichten wenn wir in
Deutschland unsere Wirtschaft
Herunterfahren werden die Welt und
insbesondere die Entwicklungsländer
davon nicht profitieren im Gegenteil das
Weltwirtschaftswachstum und damit auch
die Entwicklung in diesen Ländern würde
gebremst werden und Menschen in
unvorstellbare Armut enden und jetzt
würde ich gerne von Herrn stockwissen
Verzicht ist ja immer nett wenn es
Social Media Zeit ist oder man gönnt
sich mal doch nicht in einen Kaffee wenn
man genug hat aber was empfinden Sie
denn als Wirtschaftsjournalist bei dem
Statement von Frau Henneberger immerhin
sitzt die im Bundestag und ja regiert ja
mit also ich kann da ihre Position gut
verstehen und auch gut nachvollziehen
und ich finde dieses diesen Tweet auch
nicht in Ordnung ich würde allerdings an
einer Stelle widersprechen ich glaube es
ist eben nicht asozial und es ist
durchaus möglich sich so zu äußern weil
wir genau das in einer in einer Debatte
in einer demokratischen Debatte brauchen
das auch diejenigen die nicht betroffen
sind trotzdem Stellung beziehen können
also es ist muss möglich sein dass
jemand der nicht hungert der reich ist
der wohlhabend ist was zum zur Armut
oder zum Wohlstand in dieser Welt sagt
und genau das hat sie gemacht deswegen
meine ich dass es in der demokratischen
Debatte ist das möglich inhaltlich finde
ich auch daneben sie sagen also
zusammengefasst es ist richtig dass sie
sich dazu äußern und ihre Meinung sagt
aber inhaltlich stimmen Sie nicht zu
dass die größte besser für die Welt ist
das ist sicherlich nicht besser für die
Welt und wir müssen wir brauchen
Wachstum um immer mehr Menschen auch
einfach ernähren zu können
Fortschritt beinhaltet einfach Wachstum
und wenn wir das nicht haben dann geht
es uns allen schlechter und deswegen das
ist eine These da würde ich niemals
zustimmen aber sie ist möglich natürlich
ist möglich Herr Herbst sie sitzen ja
eigentlich neben Frau Henneberger könnte
man ja so sagen das ist jetzt nur
bildlich gesprochen ich weiß dass sie
nicht nebeneinander im Bundestag sitzen
wenn ich sie ganz plump fragen darf wie
halten sie das denn eigentlich aus mit
den Grünen ja die FDP ist eine tolerante
Partei insofern halten wir es mit den
aus aber klar wir sind als
Bundestagsabgeordneter Verantwortung
dass wir Wohlstand steigern wenn man ja
mehr Wohlstand generieren und ohne
Wachstum kein Fortschritt und wenn wir
in andere Länder schauen die ja noch
unseren Wohlstand erreichen wollen kann
das Modell bestimmt nicht sein wir
schrumpfen wir werden Arm das wird nicht
funktionieren das diskutieren wir dann
nachher auch noch beim Thema Energie ich
glaube wir müssen einfach zeigen dass
unser wohlstandsmodell funktioniert dass
wir es auch nachhaltig gestalten das ist
ein Auftrag aber es geht nicht um
stromfunkverarmung und Verzicht aber
wenn sie sagen die FDP ist offen und
freiheitslieben und er Trick das dann
ist es nicht fast schon eine
Entschuldigung dafür dass Sie dann den
Wirtschaftskurs der Grünen ich muss
sagen auch Herr Habeck unser
Wirtschaftsminister macht ja jetzt
bislang nicht den besten Job oder würden
Sie da widersprechen naja wir helfen ihm
ja ein bisschen zwei Atomkraftwerke
laufen jetzt schon länger und er hat
verstanden dass Energien Lebenselixier
für ein Land ist und Wohlstand ohne
preiswerte bezahlbare Energie nicht
funktioniert auch nicht ohne
zuverlässige Energieversorgung und ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen unser
Auftrag auch in dieser Koalition dafür
sorgen dass auch die wirtschaftlichen
Belange nicht zu kurz kommen und nicht
nur wünsche dir was passiert oder ja
irgendwelche Grünen wollen wir sehen
schon die beiden FDP-Wirtschaftsminister
als Herr Habeck ich bin ganz froh dass
Christian Lindner auf dem Geld sitzt
weil wenn das nicht so wäre habe ich ein
ungefähre Vorstellung wo wir heute
stehen würden dann hätten wir das
Problem was ins Großbritannien hat eine
noch galoppieren
schon zu den 200 Milliarden dann ganz
viele gesagt wer soll das denn
zurückzahlen und wie asozial ist den
jüngeren gegenüber ja
Generationengerechtigkeit ist immer ein
Thema aber natürlich wenn die Wirtschaft
den Bach runtergezeit auch niemand mehr
Steuern das ist eine schwierige
Entscheidung zugegebenermaßen aber ich
glaube so dass wir gesagt und die Hilfen
nur für die Energiepreise und nicht für
irgendwelche anderen Wünsche das ist der
richtige Weg
vorsitzen ich habe auch nichts anderes
erwartet habe wenn ich sie einmal fragen
darf wie sehen Sie das denn wenn Sie den
Tweet von der Dame sehen haben wir über
unsere Verhältnisse gelebt
also das kommt darauf an wen wir unter
wir verstehen ich ich möchte jetzt
vielleicht direkt auch ein bisschen eine
Lanze für die Grünen brechen sitzt ja
niemand darf in den grünen der oder die
sich da jetzt sozusagen zum Verteidiger
auf zum Verteidiger nicht ich habe
durchaus auch Schwierigkeiten immer mehr
mit der Partei mit dem grünen sowohl in
Österreich als auch in Deutschland das
hat sich auch in der corona-politik
gezeigt und da bin ich auch sicher nicht
der einzige aber was sicher fakt ist
das Wort die grows ist jetzt überhaupt
nicht mein Vokabular aber wir haben
schon ein Problem übersetzen
schrumpfende Wirtschaft die Wirtschaft
an sich in Summe muss vielleicht nicht
schumpfen sie muss sich fairer verteilen
also die Wirtschaft muss fair werden im
globalen Sinn also es muss eine faire
und eine Chancengleichheit und auch eine
Ressource eine faire
Ressourcenverteilung da sein damit eben
auch Menschen aus jetzt nachteiligen
benachteiligten Regionen oder auch die
Biodiversität des Planeten genau das
Schlimme wenn wir die groß haben leiden
Gardinen entwickeln denn wir haben ja
hier wir haben sozusagen sprechen wir
haben sowas wie Oligopole riesige
Konzerne die sich in den verschiedenen
Sparten alles unter den Nagel reißen und
dann die ganze Welt damit beglücken und
da werden dann auch kleinbauerinnen und
Kleinbauern in Südamerika in Afrika in
in Asien und anderen Ländern werden
immer mehr unter Vertrag gestellt
teilweise verlieren die auch ihr Land
sind dann nur mehr Erntehelfer wir haben
eine Agroindustrie die mit ihren
hochleistungszüchtungen die ganze Welt
für den Klimawandel
Klimawandel ist nicht das einzige Thema
der Klimawandel ist ja nur ein Aspekt
eines großen umweltwandels das große
Thema ist die Biodiversität die
schwindet unsere Ökosysteme schwinden
hinweg die Lebensräume der Menschen und
wir brauchen eine Wirtschaft die wieder
mehr auch auf das etwas dezentraler
funktioniert und und wo dann auch
Menschen also wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
sind die großen Heilsbringer wenn wir
mit unseren gentechnisch veränderten
Saatgut nach Südamerika nach Afrika nach
Asien gehen und glauben dass das die
Probleme dort bekämpft dann muss ich
sagen die Realität sieht anders aus was
dort gebraucht würde sind da reden sie
jetzt über fairere Bedingungen wir reden
aber auch nicht eine
etwas ein mehr Autonomie mehr Subsistenz
mehr wieder dort angepasste Sorten in
der Landwirtschaft zum Beispiel das
wieder dort das Know-how wieder wachsen
kann das ist ja auch dort vorhanden ja
dass wir nicht überall mit unseren
großen Konzernen alles okkupieren
sozusagen also von dem her die grows
würde ich in einem positiven Sinn so
verstehen dass man sagt es muss diese
geballte wirtschaftliche Macht in den
Händen großer Konzerne das muss man dazu
tatsächlich drei Mal noch mal für Sie
auch was die auch bedeutet das bedeutet
wie Sie es wahrscheinlich dann auch
wollen zum Beispiel Konzerne zerschlagen
oder auch nicht mehr mit dem Auto fahren
nicht mehr fliegen Verzicht üben das ist
ja auch sehr viel die groß was schönes
also ich verzichte gerne mal auf Social
Media Zeit da übe ich mich in Verzicht
aber ich kann es auch und habe auch
sonst alle Möglichkeiten dementsprechend
sie fordern wenn Sie das fordernd ist
natürlich eine legitime these aber dann
fordern Sie Verzicht verzichten sie denn
schon auf Autofahrten
aber wie gesagt diese diese globale
Gerechtigkeit kann nur hergestellt
werden wenn nicht diese gesamte
wirtschaftspolitische Macht in den
Händen des Westens unter
Anführungszeichen ist und es zu
ausbeutungsverhältnissen in anderen
Regionen kommt und Verzicht also ich
will mich nicht ich mache zum Beispiel
steigt zum Beispiel nicht ins Flugzeug
aus ökologischen Gründen schon längere
Zeit nicht mehr und komme damit auch
sehr gut klar also ich komme auch
trotzdem innerhalb Europas überall hin
ohne den Erdboden zu verlassen
ohne Probleme und also das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein Klassiker aber zum
Beispiel der Verzicht auf Fleisch ist
schon auch ein Aspekt oder dass man auf
die Quelle des Fleisches mehr achtet
wenn man Fleisch konsumiert das ist
wirklich ökologisch produziert ist denn
da spielt ja auch die Tierethik es ist
ja alles miteinander verwoben die
Tierethik eine wichtige Rolle dass man
eben auch keine ausbeutungsstrukturen in
der Tierhaltung unterstützen möchte und
solche Dinge glaube ich das sind keine
großen verzichthemen sondern das ist
eine Frage wo man die Gewichtung legt
Genuss kann zum Beispiel auch dann
stattfinden wenn man sehr viel Gemüse
ist Gemüse Vielfalt am Teller ist was
wundervolles oder eben andere
pflanzliche Produkte oder vegetarische
Produkte es muss es nicht Unmengen von
Fleisch und Wurst sein das ist für mich
persönlich kein Verzicht bevor wir den
verzichten
mit dem Flugzeug ist für mich kein
Verzicht weil ich habe Alternativen die
mich ebenso glücklich machen
wir fragen doch mal Herrn Specht worauf
verzichten sie denn Herr Specht also
darauf nicht ich verzichte momentan am
liebsten aufs Fliegen aber nicht aus
ökologischen Gründen sondern weil es
einfach so kompliziert geworden ist dass
man da gar nicht mehr richtig ankommt
wie dem Bahn fahren ist dann ist auch
ziemlich schwierig aber was ich sagen
ich sehe es natürlich ein bisschen
anders ich glaube wir haben eine
Technikfeindlichkeit entwickelt und wir
haben den Eindruck es wäre die Welt
immer schlechter geworden in den letzten
Jahrzehnten des Gegenteil ist der Fall
die Armut ist bekämpft worden in auf dem
gesamten Globus gerade weil wir den
technischen Fortschritt hatten die
Grünen haben in den 80er Jahren nein
schon in den 70er Jahren dass Mantra
ausgegeben das Gentechnik prinzipiell
schlecht wäre ich möchte nur mal kurz
daran erinnern wieder auf die Medizin
als Beispiel jeder kennt das Diabetes
wie behandeln wir das mit Insulin das
war noch Schweine Insulin man musste
Schweine
Gewebe nehmen um dieses Insulin zu
bekommen erst die Gentechnik durch die
Firma höchst damals hat es möglich
gemacht dass man das auch gen technisch
durch Bakterien herstellen kann eine
sensationelle Geschichte die die den
Prozess wesentlich reiner gemacht hat
auch aus diätischer Sicht im übrigen das
ist in Deutschland nicht möglich gewesen
sondern musste dann im Ausland gemacht
worden werden also was ich sagen möchte
ist ich glaube wir sehen zu schwarz wir
müssen deutlich positiver an dieser
herangehen und nur die gerade die
Technik allerdings natürlich klug
eingesetzt wir müssen schon einige
Veränderungen machen da bin ich bei
ihnen aber die klug eingesetzte auch
ökologisch klug eingesetzte Technik die
kann uns weiterbringen nicht ein die
crows angepasste Technik werdet wir
würden jetzt
man kann auch angepasste Technik sagen
wir lassen jetzt mal Herr Specht
Statement einmal aufstehen und seine
Meinung und kommen jetzt aber dazu war
wo vorher viele Angst haben Herr
schmeckt ich gebe Ihnen recht es gibt
übrigens ein ganz tolles Buch ich mache
hier selten Buch Werbung aber perfekt
ist ein ganz großartiges Buch was genau
beschrieben ist aber wir machen meine
Brücke zu Herrn Stock bei im Moment muss
man ja sagen hat man ja schon Panik vor
dem Absturz und Blick natürlich auch in
die Ukraine dann sehen uns heute
mitgebracht ja ich glaube wir müssen
wieder mehr über Frieden reden Frieden
uns im Moment völlig aus dem Blickwinkel
wenn wir einfach heute mal die
Nachrichten des Tages sehen wir haben
auf der einen Seite der sagt schon die
ersten russischen Rekruten gehören zu
den ersten Todesopfern das ist keine
gute Nachricht das ist eine furchtbare
Nachricht und wir wir veröffentlichen
sie wir vervielfältigen sie und sagen im
Prinzip hurra und da geht uns ein wenig
der Blickwinkel verloren die zweite
Nachricht des Tages wir sprachen schon
eben drüber ist dieser dieser
gaspreisdeckel der geschätzt die 200
Milliarden Euro kostet und diese 200
Milliarden Euro sind weg das heißt wir
haben einen Wohlstandsverlust in dieser
Höhe und wenn man auf der einen Seite
jetzt sieht diesen menschlichen Verlust
auf der anderen Seite sieht man ein
Wirtschaftskrieg den wir nicht gewinnen
werden die noch Russland nicht gewinnen
wird aber der nur Verlierer hinterlässt
dann ist diese Perspektive wie können
wir im Frieden erreichen viel wichtiger
als alles andere und sie ist uns aus der
aus der Perspektive gerutscht und um
einen ein Ziel dazu formulieren was
vielleicht auch nicht so ganz im
Mainstream ist natürlich wird es eine
Perspektive sein wo Russland eine Rolle
spielt natürlich wird es eine
Perspektive sein wo wir eine friedliche
Koexistenz mit Russland anstreben müssen
und natürlich muss es am Ende eine
Perspektive sein wo wir möglicherweise
auch ein Russland brauchen was kein
geschwächtes Russland ist was in sich
Unfrieden hat was in einer Tour sich neu
aufstellt sondern ein stabiles Russland
und diese diese Argumentation die kommt
mir im Moment viel zu kurz Hashtag sie
waren ja lange beim Handelsplatz und
jetzt beim wirtschaftskurier die die
Frage die ich mir stelle ist oder Precht
und Wälzer stellen die ja gerade in
ihrem Buch die haben mir ein Buch über
die vierte Gewalt geschrieben aber die
selbst an Gleichung der Medien und gehen
da auch mit der Ukraine
Berichterstattung ins Gericht muss man
sagen
haben wir die Medien auch einen Fehler
gemacht das ist zu wenig Diplomatie gibt
wie haben sie den medialen Diskurs über
das Thema Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn
wahrgenommen der ist gelinde gesagt
einseitig ich denke das Journalisten wir
gehören alle dazu wir beide sicherlich
das Journalisten die Pflicht haben beide
Seiten zu sehen sie haben eigentlich
auch das Gebot sich zwischen die Stühle
zu setzen und sich nicht auf einem Stuhl
zu setzen und ich glaube dass diese
dieser mediale Diskurs der ist sehr
einseitig im Augenblick ich bedauere das
ich kann es aber auch nicht ändern wir
können das auch nicht ändern und
natürlich schlägt auch irgendwo das Herz
das ist ganz natürlich aber am Ende sind
wir hier
von einer Seite sehr stark mit
Informationen gefüttert und kennen die
andere Seite nicht genau und bemühen uns
zu wenig darum in diesem in diesem
Dschungel wirklich mal nach der nach der
Wirklichkeit zu forschen würden sie auch
bei Precht und Wälzer mitgehen dass
dadurch auch die Regierung immer mehr
zum Handeln getrieben wurde weil der
Journalist muss ganz klar diese Richtung
vorgegeben hat ich hoffe eigentlich dass
Herbst jetzt hier dass wir Politiker
haben dass wir regierende haben die sich
nicht zu sehr von der veröffentlichten
Meinung treiben lassen sondern mehr
dafür treiben lassen was wofür sie
stehen wofür sie gewählt worden sind und
wofür sie hoffentlich auch eine Haltung
haben Herbst einseitige
Berichterstattung kritisch mit der
eigenen Zunft ist vielleicht auch die
Politik zu einseitig wurde zu wenig
Diplomatie gewagt also der These würde
ich ganz klar widersprechen denn wenn
wir uns erinnern in den Wochen vor dem
einmarschen die Ukraine gab es sich
Gespräche von allen großen
Staatspräsidenten der westlichen Welt
und die
der Präsident wir haben telefoniert und
Putin hat allen gesagt ich marschiere
nicht ein das ist eine Übung ich sammle
nur das Militär an der Grenze aber ich
mache hier nicht ein das war ja glaube
ich auch unsere Hoffnung am Ende des
Tages dass sie diese Droge werde aufbaut
vielleicht auch um irgendwie eine Grimm
dann irgendwie Zugeständnisse erreichen
aber dass sie dieses einmarschieren
nicht macht und dann hat er es halt
gemacht und ich glaube ich spätestens an
dem Moment wusste man man kann sich
nicht mehr verlassen
aber sorry wenn jemand ein Land
überfällt brutales unterjochen will dem
Land abstreit als Nationen existieren
ich meine das ist ja ein Unding das wäre
wie wenn wir sagen würden die Schweiz
die gibt's gar nicht als Nation so wir
machen jetzt ein weil wir haben die
Stärke wir überfallen jetzt einfach ich
meine das ist Imperial 19 bis 18
jahrhunderter wir sind uns ja eigentlich
in dieser Analyse und wir sind uns auch
eigentlich darin dass das ein ein durch
nichts zu gerechtfertigender
Angriffskrieg gewesen ist oder immer
noch ist aber wie gehen wir denn jetzt
weiter mir geht's ja darum jetzt eine
Perspektive für eine Lösung zu finden
die am Ende auf eine ja auf einem
Frieden auf eine friedliche ko Lizenz
hinwirkt und da sehe ich im Moment diese
Perspektive nicht sondern im Gegenteil
es baut ein Schritt auf den anderen auf
jetzt ist das sind die Gasleitung
weggeschlagen wahrscheinlich durch
Sabotage wahrscheinlich durch Russland
keiner weiß es so genau aber mit jedem
Schritt kommen wir einer ja einem
Dritten Weltkrieg näher anstatt dass wir
mal Inhalten und sagen verdammt was
können wir denn tun um von diesem wie
auf Schienen vorgezeichneten Weg
herunterzukommen darum geht es mir was
ist der nächste Schritt der uns mal weg
von diesem Szenario dritter Weltkrieg
bringt also ich glaube dass die
Gesprächskanäle im Hintergrund nach wie
vor offen sind sei nicht so das gar
nicht miteinander gesprochen wird nur
ich glaube jetzt im Moment muss Putin
lernen der Preis ist einfach zu hoch das
ist natürlich ein sein Denken ein ganz
schwieriger Prozess weil er nicht wie
wir sag mal rationaler darüber nachdenkt
auch nicht durch den demokratisches
Parlament kontrolliert wird auch jetzt
keine Fraktion hat die ihm dann druck
macht na man sieht ja wie auch eine
SPD-Fraktion miteinander kämpft was man
jetzt macht ich glaube wir müssen ihn
stoppen und er muss merken er hat mehr
zu verlieren als zu gewinnen ich glaube
dann ist dann ganz gute Stichwort ich
habe mich heute gefragt ihr
Parteivorsitzender unser Finanzminister
Christian Lindner hat er gesagt wir
finden uns in einem energiekrieg als
Frau Wagenknecht das noch gemacht hat
vor ein paar Wochen wurde sie eigentlich
mehrheitlich dafür verprügelt jetzt ist
es in Ordnung Energie kriegt zu sagen
aber wo sind denn unsere Waffen im Krieg
braucht doch eigentlich jede Partei
Waffen wo sind denn die Waffen von uns
wir sind am energiekrieg was sind unsere
Waffen womit wir Pudding stoppen können
na ich glaube die gesamte westliche Welt
hat von dem was sie an Potenzial hat
wirtschaftliche Macht auch militärische
Macht ist nicht wie aus Deutschland die
Bundeswehr muss erstmal modernisiert
werden wieder aber hat natürlich was
ganz anderes in die marktschelle zu
werfen als Russland man hat ja gesehen
dass nicht mal die russische Armee
eigentlich so toll ist wie sich selbst
darstellt dass da einfachste Sachen
nicht funktionieren verrostete Gewehre
Panzer die nicht mehr fahren und das
selbst die Mobilisierung eigentlich zum
Teil zum saß in Russland würden ich habe
ein bisschen die Hoffnung bei allem
natürlich was auch Russland schwierig
ist ist ein riesen Land und leben auch
nicht alle Leute in Moskau oder Sankt
Petersburg aber das irgendwann die Leute
sagen das machen jetzt nicht mehr mit
jetzt trifft unsere wir sind nicht
bereit uns zu opfern für diesen
wahnsinnigen im Kreml um uns quasi in
Ukraine dann den Sack zurück einmal bei
den Waffen ganz ganz kurz also zum
Beispiel Gabor Steiner der
Wirtschaftsjournalist hat ja bei Frau
Maischberger gesagt wir schießen nicht
Putin ins Knie sondern der eigenen
Bevölkerung wenn man sich das anschaut
muss man sagen und das können wir auch
Herrn Stock noch mal kurz fragen aber
dass die Wirtschaftssanktionen ja
bislang nicht so sind dass wir nicht
leiden und Russland total leidet das
sind wir glaube ich einer Meinung völlig
eine Meinung aber ich glaube es gibt
keine sanktionsfall der nur in eine
Richtung wirkt also Sanktionen wirken
immer zwei Richtungen und unsere
Hoffnung ist natürlich dass die
Auswirkung auf die russische Wirtschaft
dramatischer ist wenn die keine Hightech
Produkte mehr bekommen können Sie gar
nichts mehr machen sie sind auf
westliche Hightech Produkte angewiesen
die bekommen sie auch nicht aus China
und deshalb wird das schon eine
Auswirkung haben aber nicht über Nacht
das gehört zur Wahrheit dazu und
natürlich vor Ort für uns auch diesen
Schmerzen
es ist ein Wirtschaftskrieg und gesagt
ist eben Wirtschaftskrieg kann keiner
gewinnen wir haben einen
Wohlstandsverlust das ist im Moment das
was wir in die Waagschale schmeißen die
Russen haben es ganz genauso und am Ende
stehen zwei Verlierer da und was haben
wir denn bitteschön davon deswegen es
muss Schluss sein damit und wie kann
denn eigentlich Schluss sein damit ich
glaube wir sind nicht mehr als als
Europäer als der Westen eine eine Partei
die der Vermittler sein kann dazu sind
wir viel zu sehr Partei das heißt wir
brauchen andere möglicherweise ist es
sogar so jemand wieder türkische
Staatspräsident aber was wir auch
brauchen ist eine klare Definition wie
weit wir denn eigentlich gehen wollen
was ist denn eigentlich das Kriegsziel
am Ende ist es das Kriegsziel eine
Wiederherstellung der Ukraine wie vor
dem 24 februar ist es das Kriegsziel
einer Wiederherstellung der Ukraine wie
vor dem Einmarsch der Russen auf die
Krim vor 2014 und das ist alles mir viel
zu unklar und beinhaltet eben dahin dass
dieser Krieg immer weiter ausruft wir
haben ja schon Phantasien dass wir ein
Putin irgendwie stürzen muss das ist
finde ich das ist Sache der Russen sie
haben ihn gewählt dann müssen sie ja
versuchen wie sie wieder loswerden das
ist nicht unser Ding und diese diese
Definition das ist unser Ziel bis dahin
kämpfen wir bis dahin unterstützen wir
die Ukraine mit Waffen so gut es geht
aber dann ist auch wirklich vorbei dann
müssen wir zu einer Waffenruhe kommen
das Gerät uns aus der Blick aus dem
blickwinkelexperte ich möchte sie auch
nicht zum Mutmaßung bringen aber sie
haben ja definitiv auch eine Meinung als
ich habe vor allen Dingen eine Frage und
die würde ich auch an Herrn Stock
stellen möchten das ist ja die ganze
Zeit überlege ich mir das schon bin ich
jetzt für Sanktionen oder dagegen und
ich habe seit zwei Monaten keine
eindeutige Antwort darauf ich finde für
beides wunderbare Argumente ist es aber
nicht so wenn man sagt man möchte jetzt
Frieden haben ich glaube das will jeder
für mich die russische Seite nicht
vielleicht der Putin nicht aber ich
glaube alle anderen schon wenn man das
sagt ist es dann nicht notwendig dass
ein Putin aber auch verhandlungsbereit
also wissen wir denn was er will kann
man sich vorstellen dass ein Herr Putin
an einem Tisch zusammensitzt und sagt
okay ich will was weiß ich die
Ostgebiete in der Ukraine haben das ist
das Mindeste was ich haben muss und
vielleicht diese oder jene Geschichte
und dann höre ich auch und dann höre ich
auf ist ist er so wir bekommen ja
zumindest immer das Bild dass er eben
genauso nicht gestrickt ist sondern dass
man mit ihm gar nicht verhandeln kann
wäre das nicht eine Voraussetzung dass
man sagt ja wir sehen eine Chance das
mit dem verhandeln kann ich glaube wir
kennen ihn beide nicht das braucht man
nicht zu spekulieren und das was wir
sehen ist dass er Unsicherheit
verbreitet und dazu gehört eben auch
alle anderen im Unklaren zu lassen das
scheint mir eine Strategie so wie geht
man damit um
wenn die die Antwort darauf ist auch
selber Unsicherheit zu verbreiten dann
kommen wir nicht weiter aber wenn aber
die Antwort ist wir wollen eine
souveräne Ukraine in den Grenzen vom 14
vom 24 20 februar dieses Jahr ich denke
das ist so oder ist das ein ganz klarer
eine ganz klare Botschaft und wenn wir
sagen dafür setzen wir alles ein was wir
können von Waffen bis zur bis zur
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen dann ist das
zumindest mal eine klare Haltung die man
dem entgegensetzen kann ob das zu einer
Verhandlungen führt mag sein das mag vor
allen Dingen dann sein wenn wir wie im
Augenblick noch in seiner Position
die Ukraine haben die wie eine stärkere
Position ist die eine offensive Position
ist ich glaube dass man eben in so einer
Offensive eher Verhandlungen anstreben
kann als in der Defensive wir können
nicht die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine als Deutscher verhandeln also
ich finde das eine ganz schwierige
Situation das ist sie haben ein riesen
Opfer zu bringen gerade als Land leiden
immens und ich glaube es muss die
Ukraine am Ende sagen was sie will und
zu welchem Preis am Ende sie am Ende
auch zu Gesprächen bereit ist weil ich
glaube am Anfang war die
Gesprächsbereitschaft da natürlich jetzt
mit der mit dem Einfall in die ostok
rein in den ganzen Verbrechen die wir
erlebt haben mit Folter und so weiter
also dann würde ich auch nicht mehr
bereit sein mit den absprechen sehr
guter Punkt wo sie sagen wir können
nicht über die Territorien entscheiden
da stimmt ihn vermutlich hier jeder zu
am Tisch aber hat man nicht langsam das
Gefühl dass viele Politiker das Gefühl
haben die Ukraine ist Bundesland von
Deutschland also wenn ich mir manche
Tweets anschaue und manche Aktion
anschaue da muss ich schon sagen man hat
schon manchmal das Gefühl als wären wir
jetzt schon ein Land und müssten
gemeinsam kämpfen und dann wäre auch
wieder die Frage offen ob wir nicht
mitreden müssen bei den Territorien also
wenn man sich manche Twitter-Accounts
auch anguckt vom Politikern kostet
unsere Historie würde ich die Diskussion
nicht aufmachen über fremde Territorien
zu diskutieren ich glaube die Sympathien
sind mit der Ukraine
da bin ich natürlich auch absolut
dagegen meine Frage ist ob die Politik
nicht fast schon zu weit geht sich so
sehr mit der Ukraine zu beschäftigen
nein ich glaube es ist richtig dass wir
uns damit beschäftigen der Konflikt ist
ja die Ukrainer leiten am Ende leiden
wir auch in ganz Europa das ist aber
nicht vergessen die hohen Preise das
macht uns allen Stück fertig ne das
kostet uns Wohlstand sie haben das
zurecht gesagt und zwar ganz Europa und
es geht über darüber hinaus und es
trifft natürlich auch die Länder und die
Menschen die nicht so viel Geld haben
die nicht so viel Wohlstand haben die
müssen jetzt noch mal quasi auf
Wohlstand verzichten das macht es
schwierig auch diese Anteilnahme wir
werden alle froh wenn diese kriegen
morgen vorbei wäre ich möchte aber noch
ein Beispiel hinzufügen weil das für
diese territorialfrage interessant ist
ich beziehe mich auf den Jom Kippur
Krieg das war in den 70er Jahren die
Israelis wurden überfallen von Ägypten
von Syrien sie waren kurz auf dem
Rückzug und haben dann sehr schnell sind
die Offensive gekommen und sind nach
vorne gerückt und hatten die Möglichkeit
sehr weit nach Ägypten hinein zu
marschieren und in dem Augenblick hat
damals der US-Außenminister gesagt
Kissinger was ist hierher und nicht
weiter dann unterstützen wir euch
Israelis als Verbündete nicht mehr das
heißt dort hat sich eine Großmacht
eingemischt und hat gesagt ja jetzt ist
aber Schluss und das werden wir also wir
würden auch nicht akzeptieren dass die
Ukrainer jetzt nach rostefanten
einmarschieren
das als Beispiel dafür dass es durchaus
möglich ist auch mit verbündeten
Tacheles zu reden ich würde hier gerne
einmal Herrn Arbeit Fragen auch als
Bürger sehr gerne ihre emotionalen
Empfindungen Putin muss man schon sagen
droht ja manchmal auch mit Atomwaffen
haben sie Angst vor einer Eskalation
also gerade im Vorfeld haben wir darüber
gesprochen offensichtlich ich bin ja
kein politikexperte als
Biowissenschaftler droht diese Gefahr
noch immer eines Weltkriegs eines
Atomschlags und ja das ist schon etwas
wenn man das immer wieder hört auch von
Menschen die sich mehr damit befassen
wie von ihnen und von ihnen
das natürlich besorgt macht und ich
merke schon es wird man man oder ich
schiebst zur Seite ich blende es aus
also ich bin ja auch selbst Vater und
denke vielen vielen anderen Eltern wird
es ähnlich gehen man denkt natürlich
auch an die eigenen Kinder
steht Ihnen vielleicht doch so etwas wie
ein Krieg bevor ich hoffe es nicht und
ich bin zuversichtlich dass es nicht
passieren wird aber wir sehen ja auch
dass die Dinge sich teilweise sehr ja in
eine auch bedenkliche Richtung
entwickeln und das ist sehr schwer zu
sein scheint da irgendwie einzulenken
und was ich mir von unseren
verantwortungsträgerinnen und Trägern in
Europa definitiv Wünsche ist die
Eskalation also nicht
noch mehr Öl ins Feuer zu gießen auch
wenn vieles an Kritik gegen Russland
absolut gerechtfertigt ist und ich weiß
auch mir ist auch bewusst dass es ein
Angriffskrieg war aber ich sehe auch in
den in der Medienlandschaft oft sowas
wie Schadenfreude oder Häme jetzt gegen
Russland aufkeimen wo ich mir denke auch
wenn ich es nachvollziehen kann bitte
Vorsicht weil wir wollen nicht
provozieren sie dafür ein Beispiel mit
der Häme also wenn zum Beispiel gesagt
wurde russische Soldaten sind weniger
wert oder
vorhin schon genannt also mit den Toten
russischen russischen Soldaten ist
natürlich es ist genauso schlimm wenn
russische Soldaten sterben die ja auch
wieder Instrumente sind Opfer sind Krieg
ist immer schlimm für beide Seiten oder
auch dieses ein so ein Hauch von
Schadenfreude wenn wenn Russland einen
sozusagen einstecken muss was was ich
auch nachvollziehen kann aber ich glaube
man muss etwas vorsichtiger sein gerade
wenn man es eben mit einem Machthaber zu
tun hat der nicht berechenbar
offensichtlich ist und ich würde mir von
allen Beteiligten Deeskalation im Sinne
eines möglichst raschen Friedens
wünschen und damit meine ich jetzt
unseren unsere
Verantwortungsträger die amerikanische
Seite alle es sind mir zu viele in
globale big players mit ihren Interessen
irgendwie dahin involviert aber das
wichtigste ist dass die Menschen in der
Ukraine Ukraine wieder Frieden haben das
muss das höchste und schnellst möglichst
schnell anstrebbar sein
Frieden wünscht sich glaube ich hier da
ist ein rasches Ende hat da sind sich
glaube ich alle am Tisch einer Meinung
aber sie haben es eben schon
angesprochene Herbst auch uns betreffen
die Wirtschaft Sanktionen stark und ich
glaube wo man sich auch gegenseitig
Recht geben wird ist dass wir zu lange
abhängig waren dass man das jetzt sieht
und sie haben dazu heute auch eine These
mitgebracht ich glaube dass die hohen
gasenstrompreise die wir erleben auf
Dauer nicht durchhaltbar sind für unser
Land und neben den Hilfsmaßnahmen die
wir jetzt einleiten müssen wir auf dem
Markt einfach mehr Energie anbieten das
heißt für mich dass wir nicht nur jetzt
die beiden Atomkraftwerke bis zum
Frühjahr weiterlaufen lassen weil das
Problem nach diesem Winter nicht vorbei
sein wird wir brauchen länger Kernkraft
ich glaube wir sollten auch über die
Reaktivierung der stillgelegen
Kernkraftwerke nachdenken und aus meiner
Sicht auch über mehr Einheimische
Erdgasförderung denn es ist absurd dass
wir aus den USA frechen Gas importieren
wollen aber selbst nicht bereit sind Gas
in Deutschland zu fördern
Herbst hier habe ich die Frage die
ostsee-pipelines die Beschäftigen ein
Jahr sehr stark und wir wollen hier
definitiv nicht mutmaßen aber weiß man
schon mehr im Bundestag nein wir tappen
genauso im Dunkeln wieder allgemeine
Öffentlichkeit also wer die sabotiert
hat wissen wir nicht dass es keine
natürliche Ursache war ist Glas waren
Explosion die extern ausgeführt worden
zu zufällig und man darf ja nicht
vergessen die die notstream 2 ist ja
völlig neu die Pipeline also die war ja
noch nicht mal in Betrieb das heißt vom
Material kann es keine Materialermüdung
sein aber glauben Sie oder denken Sie
dass es einen Weg zurück gibt zu den
Handelsbeziehungen mit Russland also ich
glaube unter Putty nicht ehrlich gesagt
und ich glaube die zweite Lehre ist wir
sollen uns nie wieder so abhängig von
einem Lieferanten machen wir waren bei
55% erdgasimporten von Russland abhängig
das würde ich auch mit keinem anderen
Land mehr machen egal welches Land auf
der Welt man sollte immer
diversifizieren auch kein Unternehmen
würde 70 Prozent des Umsatz mit einem
einzigen Kunden machen weil wenn der weg
bricht bist du auch noch neben dem Platz
war ein anderes Land vergleichbar
abhängig was gefällt naja die Italiener
sind abhängig auch von von
Gaslieferungen gewesen und ich sag mal
wir müssen diversifizieren und ich
glaube der Fehler war dass wir so eine
Energiewende gemacht haben die hieß wir
bauen ein paar Windräder an Land auf und
die gesamte Reserve bei Windstille das
machen wir alles mit russischem Gas und
damit ist die Energiewende krachen
gescheitert wir müssen auf mehrere
Standbeine setzen dazu gehört dass man
sich Kernkraft offshore Windkraft weil
die einfach zuverlässiger ist auch Solar
aber eben auch einheimischer
tracken wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden
habe dass wir die Reserven nutzen
sollten das kann sicher gemacht werden
das zeigen ja auch die seriösen Studien
die es heute gibt dass wenn man das
sauber ausführt dass man das ordentlich
machen kann und wir haben ungefähr ein
Reserven das 30-fache des deutschen
Jahres Gasverbrauchs was bei uns im
Boden liegt und hat auch eine
wirtschaftliche Komponente warum sind
wir nur anderen Ländern für Gas Geld
zahlen warum nutzen wir nicht selbst die
wirtschaftlichen Potenziale wird das
aktuell auch besprochen also ich stelle
mir erstmal den Grünen relativ schwierig
vor übers Tracking zu reden ist auch
schwierig auch Atom ist mit grünen
schwierigen und ich finde wir müssen
jetzt eigentlich mal lernen wir können
uns nicht anderen abhängig machen und
insbesondere von unsicheren Kandidaten
also wenn wir jetzt Strom aus Österreich
beziehen würde ich sagen können wir uns
darauf verlassen da gibt es einen
freundschaftliches Verhältnis auf sie zu
bewegen ja toben war ja eine ungeheure
herumeierei also man hätte doch ehrlich
gesagt schon jetzt im Sommer sagen
müssen die Kernkraftwerke bleiben am
Netz auch dem Markt im Signal zu geben
wir geben die Energie stellen wir
zuverlässig zur Verfügung
aber wir kämpfen darum weil ich glaube
die Macht ist faktischen wird uns alle
einholen ja weil sie sind Ökologe und
damit auch Umweltexperte
selbstverständlich es gibt ja auch
Nachteile beim Fracking und bei
verschiedenen Energielösungen ja es ist
es ist ein massiver Eingriff in in
Gleichgewichte des Erdmantels die wir
schwer abschätzen können in ihren Folgen
und ich bin immer dagegen komplexe
natürliche Systeme die sich über
Jahrmillionen entwickelt haben über Jahr
Milliarden
so massiv zu beeinflussen dass mögliche
Schäden in vielen Menschen Generationen
nicht mehr in Ordnung gebracht werden
können und es gibt Alternativen das
selbe gilt ja auch für den Atomstrom
also wo ja allein die die
lagerproblematik nicht gelöst ist weil
es hat unendlich also sehr lange
Halbwertszeiten und wir greifen da ja in
zukünftige Generationen ein aber mit
jeder Tradition
Amerika gefreut wird das ist immer das
was ich mich frage nein es ist egal wo
das passiert also amerikanische Tracking
Energie ist genauso meiner Meinung nach
abzulehnen aber es gibt so viele
Alternativen inzwischen ich weiß nicht
ob sie es wissen also meine Verlobte und
ich wir recherchieren gerade für ein
einen Dokumentarfilm über ökologische
Energieproduktion und ökologische
Lebensformen und Dank an sie wir haben
jetzt ein sehr interessantes Konzept
entdeckt das ist das die beefazialen
Solarpanels Panels also dass man auf
beiden seitenkollektoren hat
und das können Sie auf diesen riesigen
Agrarflächen die überall in Deutschland
Österreich und überall haben in ganz
Europa können Sie also streifenweise
diese diese
Paneele senkrecht aufstellen so dass Sie
also kaum Fläche brauchen und auch die
Landwirtschaft in den Ackerbau dort
nicht beeinträchtigen und von bei je
nachdem wie die Sonne steht ob sie jetzt
im Osten steht oder im Westen steht je
nach Tageszeit nimmt eben die eine Seite
oder die andere Seite Energie aus
damit können Sie gigantische Flächen
ausstatten und die Landwirtschaft kann
die Landwirtschaft kann auch ein wichtig
eine wichtige Säule der
Energieproduktion werden ganze
Stallungen wir haben auch große
Stallungen und Lagerhallen die können
bedeckt werden mit mit Solarenergie mit
Solarpaneelen Speicherprobleme
lässt sich auch lösen und es gibt
Landwirte die haben in Deutschland die
haben diese Anlagen und sie bräuchten
nur noch den Schalter umlegen und
könnten aufs Netz gehen sie dürfen nicht
auch die anderen Argumente ich will alle
von ihnen heute Abend noch hören aber
einmal ganz kurz Herr Stock wenn Sie das
Hören hört sich dass sie an als könnte
die Energiekrise heute abend gelöst
werden hier am Tisch von 8:15 Uhr wäre
schön wir blicken Sie denn darauf das
Licht ausmachen da macht es gleich gehen
aber nein ich krieg da also ich finde
diese Vorschläge faszinierend und je
mehr sie davon erzählen desto mehr
bringen sie das auch zum Leuchten das
finde ich klasse ich glaube nur wir sind
noch ganz weit davon weg wir haben im
Moment glaube ich 17% unseres
Primärenergiebedarfs werden durch
erneuerbare Energien gedeckt das ist wir
sind meilenweit davon weg so also es
braucht und weil das er noch nicht
umgesetzt und was was ja aber auch das
ist ein Baustein und was mich immer
stört ist wenn wir uns auf gewisse
Technologien festlegen dass das Problem
wenn wir Atomkraft ausschalten mit guten
Argumenten dann verhindern wir die
Forschung an Atomkraft die vielleicht
irgendwann dazu führen wird dass wir
diese dieses Lagerproblem in den Griff
kriegen dass wir vielleicht mit einer
einer ganz anderen Technik da
Vorankommen wenn wir uns auf Kohle
festlegen dann verhindern wir das andere
Technologien vorankommen und diese diese
Festlegung aus ideologischen Gründen die
geht mir sowas von gegen den gestrich
außerdem ein Punkt dazu noch man muss
auch mal verstehen so toll das ist wenn
wir die ganze Welt mit Solarpanelen die
so super toll sind Pflastern würden
wirklich auch diesen Quadratmeter das
ist alles voll
Studio auch es würde uns nichts nutzen
es geht weil Strom kann nicht wir können
Strom aus den Solarpaneelen nur bekommen
solange die Sonne scheinen das tut sie
Gott sei Dank relativ oft in letzter
Zeit sogar häufiger aber wir können sie
nicht so speichern wir haben 36
Pumpspeicherkraftwerke in Deutschland
ist einfach geografisch da ein Ende wir
können ja nicht mehr mitmachen wir
bräuchten erstmal Speicher um diese
Mengen tatsächlich einspeichern zu
können die wir dann am Mittag zum
Beispiel produzieren die Pumpspeicher
sie wissen das wahrscheinlich die haben
bei uns eine Energie von 40 Minuten
Strom Menge mehr nicht wenn Sie alle
funktionieren würden das heißt es ist ja
richtig die Energiewende unterstütze ich
in jeder Regel wenn ich ganz toll ja und
man hätte viel mehr machen können vor
auf vollkommener Chor aber es ist
einfach falsch anzunehmen man könnte nur
mit diesen regenerativen Energien da
muss das noch mal einhaken also erstens
ich ich schade das jetzt kein Experte
für für erneuerbare Energien hier sitzt
ich bin kein Experte für erneuerbare
Energien als bio-wissenschaftler bin ich
auf die Organismen spezialisiert Mensch
Pflanze Tier und nicht auf die Technik
aber ich weiß dass es zum Beispiel
Konzepte gibt wo ganze Häuser aus sich
heraus energieautark gebaut werden
können da gibt es ein Beispiel ein ein
Konzept das nennt sich die Earth Chips
Earth das wird
geschlossener Wasserkreislauf einerseits
wird gemacht und andererseits wird eben
aufgrund von Solarenergie Windenergie
und wenn möglich auch noch Wasser in die
auf mehreren Säulen das Haus vollkommen
Energie am Tag zu machen und das dürfen
sie in Deutschland nicht die Frage
wollen sie das den Menschen vorschreiben
wollen Sie also mir sagen ich baue
gerade ein Haus wollen sie zu mir sagen
so Fasching sie müssen das machen
den letzten Jahren ökologische
Vorschriften was zum Beispiel die
Dämmstoffe betrifft gemacht das wurde
vorgeschrieben aus ökologischen Gründen
wir haben einen Planeten wir haben eine
Planeten und das ist der Planet der auch
den also das konkret nicht es ist ja
nicht einmal erlaubt momentan aber da
fängt sie schon mal an sie dürfen
heutzutage nicht einmal so ohne weiteres
ihr Haus energieautark bauen
sie müssen diesen Anschluss ans Netz
haben und da könnte man ja zumindest
einmal diese Tore öffnen das ist leicht
das denen die sie müssen jetzt müssen
Sie nicht machen aber denen die das
machen möchten und es gibt viele
Menschen die aus ökologischen Gründen
was nachhaltigen Gründen für zukünftige
Generationen das auch Freiheit machen
würden
also wenn sie darauf Freiwilligkeit
setzen das wird ja dann nicht klappen
für die komplette Energieversorgung
natürlich werden genauso wie gesagt auch
ökologische oder halt effiziente
Dämmmaterialien vorgeschrieben sind also
man sie können Haus nicht mehr heute so
bauen dass die Energie sozusagen wie in
einer Holzhütte verschwindet sondern sie
müssen da auch gewisse Standards
einhalten und das hat sich in den
letzten Jahren auch immer mehr erhöht
früher waren das die Pioniere des
ökologischen Bauens die Spinner aber
auch für unser Projekt jetzt einiges
interviewt die haben Gegenwind bekommen
heute sind deren damalige Standards
teilweise Vorschrift beim Bauen ja es
gibt Bauvorschriften und es könnte auch
noch mehr Vorschriften geben die die
müssen natürlich umsetzbar sein aber es
könnte sich in die Richtung entwickeln
dass wir viel dezentraler das wird auch
passieren dezentraler den Strom
produzieren und Überschüsse dann in ein
Netz in ein gemeinschaftliches Netz
abschicken
ja aber auch wenn wir hier nicht einer
Meinung sind dass man eine Innovation
hier vorgestellt wird
dementsprechend finde ich das toll dass
wir auch mal Innovationen besprechen und
damit gehen wir in eine ganz kurze sind
gleich wieder zurück
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und beschäftigen uns
jetzt mit einem sehr wichtigen Thema und
zwar mit der Wirksamkeit der
corona-impfstoffe das beschäftigt
nämlich ich glaube fast jeden hier in
diesem Land und damit kommen wir zur
These von der Arbeit
ich sitze heute hier weil es mich sehr
bestürzt macht wie lang es dauert bis
politische Verantwortungsträger
eingestehen dass diese Impfstoffe mehr
Nebenwirkungen haben als wir gedacht
haben und das Kosten oder das
nutzenrisikoprofil nicht so gut aussieht
wie es uns oft gesagt wurde die Aussage
von Karl Lauterbach zum Beispiel dass er
zugegeben hat unter Anführungszeichen
dass es Nebenwirkungen gibt und dann als
Beispiel genannt hat Menschen die sich
nicht mehr so gut konzentrieren können
empfinde ich als eine untragbare
Verhöhnung gegenüber Menschen die
schwerwiegende Schäden von den
corona-impfstoffen getragen haben die
hauptsächlich auf
vorhersehbare und das werde ich noch
weiter ausführen
vorhersehbare Autoimmunreaktionen
zurückzuführen sind wie zum Beispiel
Thrombosen und Blutgerinnsel die bis hin
zum Schlaganfall führen aber auch
autoimmunbedingte Entzündungen im
Nervengewebe bis hin zum Rückenmark auch
hier gab es Alarmzeichen in den
klinischen Studien vor der Zulassung die
dann Menschen mit Lähmungserscheinungen
zurücklassen Menschen die Sport
betrieben haben und plötzlich im
Rollstuhl sitzen und da gibt es jetzt
auch aktuelle neue Analysen die eben
belegen die Impfstoffe haben mehr
Nebenwirkungen und diese Verhöhnung
gegenüber den Menschen die das erleben
müssen dass das immer wieder klein
geredet wird der möchte ich
entgegentreten die Verhöhnung der
Menschen das möchte keiner her aber ich
muss ehrlich sein als ich mir natürlich
mich auf sie vorbereitet habe habe ich
mich gewundert okay einer der größten
impfskeptiker im deutschsprachigen Raum
auf jeden Fall sind sie schon oft
aufgetreten haben gewarnt und sie sind
Öko Immunologe auf welcher Basis können
Sie so gut die Impfung einschätzen na
mein Thema ist das Immunsystem ich bin
auch Doktorand im Fach Biologie
am Institut für Biologie der Universität
Graz möchte aber betonen dass ich nicht
in dieser Funktion hier sitze aber ich
bin einfach von meiner Ausbildung her
Biowissenschaftler und mein Schwerpunkt
ist schon seit längerer Zeit das
Immunsystem die ökoimmunologie
Umwelteinflüsse auf das Immunsystem und
natürlich befasse ich mich da auch
im weiteren Sinne mit mit verschiedenen
Substanzen die auf uns einwirken und bin
da auch auf das Thema der Impfstoffe und
Medikamente gestoßen ich möchte aber
gerne klarstellen dass ich kein
impfscaptiker bin die einzige Quelle die
das behauptet ist Wikipedia aber ich bin
vor Corona nie die die Quelle meine ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht sondern ihre These
die Sie gerade vorgestellt haben da
kamen sie für mich als im Skeptiker dann
müsste ich ja das Prinzip der Impfung
in Frage stellen oder kritisieren mir
geht es aber hier darum dass
ich bin auch nicht gegen die
corona-impfung das Problem ist dass es
hier zu Verkürzungen zu teleskopierungen
zum zusammenschieben wie eine
Teleskopstange zum zusammenschieben von
Abläufen der impfstoffsicherheit
gekommen ist die normalerweise Zeit
brauchen und eingehalten werden wie zum
Beispiel dass man eine Phase kein eine
klinische Phase war noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen hat schon die nächste
begonnen und so weiter also wie ein
Teleskop wie die Glieder eines Teleskops
das nennt man teleskopierung wurden
diese
Zulassungsverfahren zusammengeschoben es
gab schon ganz früh und es geht mir
wirklich nur um diese Art von Impfstoffe
weil die so gepusht wurden weil da
plötzlich wichtige Prinzipien der
Sicherheit die mediale Kampagne
gigantisch und weil plötzlich wichtige
Prinzipien der impfstoffsicherheit an
denen man vorher nicht rütteln konnte
plötzlich über Bord geworfen wurden es
geht mir nur um diesen einen Vorgang
nicht sagen dass die Bürokratie einfach
mal schneller abgebaut wurde also jeder
der Bürokratie schon mal kennengelernt
hat muss sagen wir würden da viele
Beispiele einfallen wo man das glaube
ich wenn Krise da wäre ganz schnell
abbauen könnte kann man nicht auch sagen
dass deswegen die Zulassungsverfahren
schneller waren weil einfach
zugelassen worden bevor die dritten
klinischen Phasen abgeschlossen waren
wir die laufen ja dann noch zwei Jahre
weiter manchmal sogar länger also das
sind ja Prozesse die noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen sind also allein das ist
schon ungewöhnlich aber auch eben das
einzelne z.B präklinische Phasen wurden
noch gar nicht end ausgewertet da wurden
die Impfstoffe schon an Menschen
verabreicht es gab schon sehr früh
stimmen die Zweifel und diesen
Impfstoffen und an der Sicherheit
geäußert haben und in vielen Punkten
auch recht hatten ich selbst habe 2021
darauf hingewiesen dass mit
Autoimmunreaktionen zu rechnen ist
also Ende 2020 in einem Buch und in
einem weiteren Buch dann 2021 vor der
Zulassung also es war voraussehbar zum
Beispiel sie haben früher gesagt ich
möchte ja einmal einhaken damit wir
nicht ganz viele Punkte haben und dann
erst später Antworten darf erstmal Herrn
Specht ganz kurz um seine Einschätzung
bitten also es ist jetzt gerade viel
aufgekommen Zulassungs Gefahren nicht
vorbereitet er weiß ja unglaublich weich
gespült also unglaublich weil sonst
treten sie ja in Youtube und in anderen
Dingen deutlich heftiger aus als wäre
mir eigentlich ganz lieb gewesen sie
hätten auch mal ruhig rausgehauen also
Gott sei Dank sie kennen ja viele
Menschen also viele kennen sie und da
sind Sie ja schon ein bisschen heftiger
unterwegs was sie jetzt gesagt haben da
kann ich ja fast überall ein Haken
hinter machen ich finde das gut wenn man
kritisch ist und Sie haben Recht ich
sehe das genauso die gerade die Impfung
zu Corona die ich für eine Sensation
hatte ich für wirklich für fantastisch
ist aber auf der anderen Seite von
bestimmten Kreisen sehr gepusht worden
auch da werden wir lieb gewesen man
hätte nicht immer den Eindruck gehabt
und es wurde zum Teil ja auch so gesagt
ja da gibt es vielleicht schon irgendwas
aber das haben wir bei anderen
informiert das dürfen wir jetzt aber
hier nicht so erwähnen weil das gibt
dann Echo in der falschen Kammer das
halte ich auch für absolut kritikwürdig
und deswegen ist es in Ordnung kritisch
da heranzugehen aber sie sind schon ein
nicht nur im Skeptiker sondern sie sind
schon auch ein was naja also was die
corona-impfung angeht und mit anderen
Impfungen
allerdings schon in einer recht heftigen
Weise und da kam mir so in den Sinn mit
Herrn Lauterbach habe ich ja auch so
meine eigenen Gedanken und ich glaube
viele von uns eine eigentliche Fanbase
hat er ja inzwischen verloren da gibt es
noch eine Runde fragen vielleicht ist ja
der letzte Fan von Karl Lauterbach
runter es mag ja auch noch welche geben
aber im Prinzip sind sie für mich jetzt
nicht heute hier das muss ich sagen aber
sonst sind sie für mich der Lauterbach
unter den
impfskeptikern bzw Corona im Skeptiker
nein er hat ihn den YouTube-Videos genau
das gemacht was er Lauterbach umgekehrt
auch macht er ist ein Cherry Picker sie
wissen genau was das ist also ein
herausgreifer der einzelnen Aussagen aus
Studien die einem Behagen die einem
gerade in die Richtung gehen und das
Weglassen andere Teile es gehört immer
nein nein dazu und sie schreiben mir
jetzt gerade ihre Dissertation über ich
glaube zirbelwälder und Einfluss auf den
Menschen das ist nicht der Grund weshalb
sagen muss der Mann hat keine Ahnung es
gibt Journalisten die kommt wo ganz
woanders Theo und haben sich super toll
in die mna Technologie eingearbeitet
doktoratsarbeit über den Einfluss von
Umweltfaktoren auf das Immunsystem ja
also das wie gesagt ist mit Sicherheit
auch kein kein Grund dass man da dann
keine Ahnung haben könnte aber man muss
natürlich schon gerade wenn man solche
Studien dann zitiert komplett zitieren
und wenn man die Studien meistens im
Abstract mal anschaut dann steht dann
meistens sogar das genau die Aussage die
sie daraus lesen wollen genau nicht mit
dieser Studie zum Beispiel
Langzeiteffekte herauszulesen sind ich
gebe Ihnen Recht man hat die Sache zu
einseitig gesehen
heute sind sie hier also
vielleicht sollte ich aber was sagen
das Problem ist wir sind jetzt hier
nicht in der Lage in der Sendung jede
Aussage von Herr Arbeit durchzugehen das
heißt ich weiß jetzt nicht woher Cherry
picking betrieben haben soll da muss ich
ihn jetzt erstmal einen Schutz nehmen
kann ich nicht sagen dass das stimmt der
Vorwurf aber machen wir jetzt mal ganz
konkret Herr sprecht weil viele Bürger
haben ja wirklich Angst vor der Impfung
oder sagen auch sie wollen die vierte
jetzt nicht mehr haben das sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge genau weil würden Sie
denn jetzt zum Beispiel mir als
30-jähriger Frau raten die vierte
Impfung zu machen nein nein und Herr
Arbeit wird es mir auch nicht raten nein
kann ich Ihnen nur meine privaten
aus ich sie sind total gesund total jung
20 gerade überschritten dann ich haben
sie einfach nichts davon eine Impfung
ist ein Mediziner wenn man sofort einig
lernt medizinischer Eingriff und das ist
eine tolle Sache es ist wirklich
sensationell was da gelungen ist ich bin
absolut davon überzeugt die mna-impfung
über die vektorimpfung ist wieder eine
andere Geschichte sie hatten wir
Thrombosen gesprochen anderes Thema aber
die mna-impfung hat
zig Millionen wahrscheinlich hunderte
von Millionen Menschenleben gerettet
aber sie haben aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach nichts von einer vierten Impfung
von der dritten wahrscheinlich schon
aber von der vierten nicht warum sollte
man es dann also tun sie könnte
Nebenwirkungen haben haben Sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber sie haben
keinen keinen Mehrwert davon wären sie
jetzt 85 und hätten
Begleiterkrankungen und hätten die
anderen Impfungen aber auch gut
vertragen und vielleicht hätte man sogar
eine Antikörperbestimmung mal gemacht
dann sei die Sache vielleicht ganz
anders aber genau das wurde er nicht
gemacht es wurde ja nicht selektiert und
es wurde eine Impfung ausgerollt im
Politiker für alle bis zu den Kindern
auf Basis teleskopiert der Verfahren das
halte ich für absolut fahrlässig jetzt
aber zu den zwei drei wichtigen
Beispielen weil ich muss ja auch
irgendwas sagen wo sie dann
widersprechen bitte
zum Beispiel hat man
gesehen bei astrosenecker zum Beispiel
hat man gesehen in den in den klinischen
Phasen Veränderungen im Blutbild die
darauf hingewiesen haben eine sogenannte
Neutropenie ein deutlicher Abfall
bestimmter weißer Blutkörperchen die
darauf hinweisen dass da eine
überschussüberschuss überschüssige
überschießende Immunreaktion angelaufen
ist und was wäre an sich aufgrund dieser
Signifikanz im Vergleich zu anderen
Impfstoffen ja das haben die Autoren
selber als signifikante Häufung dieses
Vorfalls angegeben schon ein
Alarmzeichen gewesen was ist die wo kann
man diese Blutgerinnsel die Thrombosen
die auch ins Gehirn die hirnven
betreffen her es ist eine überschießende
Autoimmunreaktion eine thrombotische
Thrombozytopenie das Immunsystem greift
die eigenen Thrombozyten an und dadurch
kommt zu diesen Störungen man hatte man
intellektuell bei den Fremdwörtern muss
ich Ihnen diese Art nicht konkret aber
diese Art der Autoimmunreaktionen an den
frühen klinischen Studien bereits sehen
und ich und andere die darauf
hingewiesen haben sind sofort ins Eck
der schwurbler gestellt worden sofort
Aspekt der alufut-träger Querdenker
obwohl ich zu meinem ganzen Leben davor
nicht am noch nie gehört habe was
Querdenker überhaupt sind es waren Dinge
vorhersehbar wie zum Beispiel diese
überschießenden Autoimmunreaktionen und
wie gesagt diese Blutgerinnsel diese
diese die auch bisschen zu
Schlaganfällen führen das sind
Autoimmunreaktionen in der Ursache
aufgrund der Impfung es gibt auch
Menschen die im Rollstuhl plötzlich
sitzen die Lähmungen haben aufgrund von
Autoimmunreaktionen im Nervengewebe bis
hin zum Rückenmark und da gab es auch
früher Hinweise früher Hinweise in
klinischen Studien das
rückenmarksentzündungen aufgetreten sind
und man hat es nicht man hat man hat es
nicht man hat es zu Seiten geschoben man
hat es gleich weggewischt anstatt diese
Warnsignale ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen
wir müssen besser selektieren wer die
Impfstoffe bekommt und werden zusammen
dass man differenzieren muss wer es
bekommt und wer nicht und vor allem dass
man nicht alle über einen Kamm hätte
Scheren sollen
und ich glaube da sind sich alle hier
einiges muss ich aber zu der spechtskäse
geben weil sonst der Specht schuldig
ihnen was sie nicht drankommen oh Gott
da muss ich auch noch schneller sein das
gefällt mir besonders schwer
eigentlich ist es ja jedem klar in
unserem Gesundheitswesen stimmt
irgendetwas nicht wir haben zwar eines
der besten der Welt sagt man allerdings
auch ein sehr teures wir geben etwa eine
Milliarde aus nicht im Jahr nicht in der
Woche jeden Tag ich war deutlich mehr
als ein Milliarde die Zahl der
100-jährigen steigt ständig wir werden
also sehr alt aber es sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge alt werden oder
gesund alt werden wenn man sich das mal
anschaut dann hat ein deutscher
65-jähriger gerade noch einmal
sechseinhalb Jahre gesunde Jahre vor
sich auf die er sich freuen kann ein
Norweger dagegen die Skandinavier machen
das irgendwie besser der hat noch ganze
elfeinhalb gesunde Jahre Vorsicht was
machen wir obwohl wir sehr viel mehr
sogar für die Prävention ausgeben also
die Vorbeugung als die Norweger irgendwo
kann der was nicht stimmen wir sind
Weltmeister in den Arztbesuchen wir
rennen hin das ist in unseren alten
Köpfen drin wenn du krank bist dann geh
zum Arzt wir haben unser Leben
medikalisiert wir haben überall Medizin
und wir verlangen immer mehr Medizin wir
verlangen vom selben immer noch mehr
mehr Ärzte mehr Krankenhäuser mehr Geld
für das System ich glaube wir geben
unser Geld für das falsche aus übrigens
Geld was wir so wie es alle aktuell
gerade diskutiert haben zunehmend
überhaupt nicht mehr haben und wir
brauchen und das sage ich nicht mehr
Ärzte obwohl da immer unisono Politiker
Krankenkassen Ärzte alle ein Meinungen
sind auch Patienten dass das so wäre ich
glaube wir brauchen nicht mehr Ärzte es
ist Zeit umzukehren wir müssen wieder
mehr auf uns Menschen auf unsere
Eigenverantwortung pochen die Leute mit
einbinden und selber feststellen lassen
wann gehe ich zum Arzt wann muss ich
wirklich hin wann ist es richtig wie den
Fortschritt richtig einbinden ich bin
froh über jedes neu erfundene Medikament
aber ich glaube nicht dass wir jede
Operationstechnik zum Beispiel in jedem
Alter tatsächlich anwenden sollen ist
dann kein Segen für die Menschheit Herr
Stock was tun sie denn für ihre
Prävention ich mache hier morgen
Liegestütze
und ansonsten
mache ich nichts aber ich lebe
eigentlich danach dass ich so lange das
mache wie es mir noch gut geht aber sie
schaden sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
es rauchen sie okay
[Gelächter]
aber glauben Sie denn dass die Deutschen
zu viel zum Arzt gehen gibt es da ich
glaube das ist eine eine große
Verunsicherung gibt ja das glaube ich
das ist durch
größere Angebote auch möglich ist nicht
Sicherheit zu schaffen sondern
Verunsicherung zu schaffen da gebe ich
Ihnen recht es gibt immer dieses schöne
Beispiel aus den
schlechteren Ländern Afrikas wenn sie
dann Waisenhaus hinbauen dann gibt es
mit einmal ganz viele Weise die ist
vorher gar nicht gegeben hat also wenn
Sie Ihren Krankenhaus hinbauen und viele
Ärzte werden sie auch wahrscheinlich
mehr Patienten finden das ist sicherlich
richtig ich glaube aber auch für dieses
Angebot wenn es nachgefragt ist auch
irgendwie schaffen sollten ich habe sie
hier mit einem Appell verstanden auf
sich selber zu hören und weniger zum
Arzt zu gehen das finde ich jetzt völlig
richtig und was wollen Sie denn machen
wenn die Menschen anders ticken das ist
es das ist ein ein eine Veränderung die
wir auf allen Seiten brauchen ich sage
nicht die Patienten drin sind dran
schuld oder die erste sind dran schuld
wir alle in den letzten 40 Jahren haben
uns dahin erzogen auch die Kassen haben
damit gemacht die Politiker haben auch
mitgemacht immer mehr Medizin wir haben
die Eigenverantwortung hinten angestellt
weil wir eben so viel machen können das
ist ja ganz toll haben wir aber es auch
in jeder Variante eingefordert zum
Beispiel nehmen wir mal die
Darmkrebsvorsorge die kann ja Leben
retten oder ich muss ehrlich sagen
während der corona-zeit hatte ich das
Gefühl es gibt gar keinen Krebs mehr und
heute würde ich sagen wenn jemand in
seinem Umfeld oder so ein Mann über 50
hat oder eine Frau sollte er dringend
sagen
Darmkrebsvorsorge ist ein super Beispiel
genau das ist es die beste
Vorsorgeuntersuchung die wir haben warum
weil ihnen einer einzigen Untersuchung
kann man den das dass das Ding was stört
direkt sehen und sogar noch wegnehmen
das ist genial beim Prostatakarzinom
viel schwieriger da gibt es eigentlich
keine gute Vorsorgeuntersuchung Mama
also eine Mammographie schwierig das
muss beurteilt werden dann gibt es auch
falsch positives alles alles viel
schwieriger Darmkrebs das ist so etwas
da würde man sagen unbedingt wer 50 ist
als Mann oder 55 als Frau unbedingt da
mal hin mal reinschauen lassen das ist
ein sehr schönes Schlusswort für heute
das sieht man schon durch ja wir sind
schon durch ich schulde Herr Specht noch
mal eine Einladung er ist heute ein
bisschen kurz bekommen schönen Abend
noch an sie wir sehen uns nächste Woche
Dienstag wieder tschüss und denken Sie
an die Darmkrebsvorsorge tschüss
[Musik]